what's up guys EA here with Harin X and
last week we looked at the evj GTX 1080
superclocked ACX 3.0 GPU and after
testing we concluded that it was better
than the GTX 1080 Founders Edition in
every way it was faster ran cooler and
it actually cost less money well today
we're here taking a look at our second
custom GTX 1080 and this one is from
gigabyte specifically the G1 gaming
video
card yuck okay mod configurator allows
you to select only the cables you need
with your choice of mod Flex sleeving
that is very flexible or mod mesh that
is more vibrant then you choose your
length and color combination custom
cables just got more custom with the
cable mod configurator the price point
is very much in line with the
competition out there uh coming at
around
$650 but more importantly this also
happens to be the same price as evg's
super clogged I mentioned earlier specs
wise what you're looking at is a GP 104
core that has some interesting clock
speeds since it actually comes with two
main performance modes if you install it
without gigabyt Extreme Engine software
it automatically defaults to gaming mode
and runs at 1695 MHz and 1835 MHz for
the base and boost frequencies
respectively meanwhile the software also
includes an OC mode that UPS the
performance to 17 21 MHz base with a
boost of up to 1860 MHz we've enabled OC
and these settings will be used for the
tests there's also 8 GB of gddr5x memory
and the rest of the specs are pretty
much neck to neck compared to the
founders Edition and given the higher
clock speeds we can certainly expect a
significant increase in performance
considering gigabytes Advanced windforce
3x heat SN should keep those frequencies
consistent I should also point out that
there are a lot more features packed
into this card like fully controllable
RGB lighting a custom PCB with upgraded
components and a Bend core which is
supposed to offer more overclocking
Headroom uh these are certain ways to
differentiate this particular card from
the superlong ACX 3.0 since evg's card
didn't offer any of those the G1
Gaming's design is understated when
compared against some other GTX 1080
cards on the market but I quite like it
if you recall the previous gtx980 ti1
gaming that included a minimalist black
and white shroud with an RGB lit
windforce logo on its side this 1080
version utilizes a similar
all-encompassing predominantly Black
cover with a few red highlights light uh
it is much less distinctive than EJ's
Current Designs but I think it's much
more likely to fit a broader range of
builds the windforce 3x cooler has
historically been one of the best
regarded heat sinks around uh by
utilizing a large horizontally placed
heat sink which runs throughout the card
gigabyte has been able to effectively
maximize dissipation while also ensuring
their direct touch heat pipe base has
enough thermal Mass above it to keep up
with its core output uh That Base has
been revised this time around so it's
heat p all make contact with the smaller
GP 104 core however there's one
sacrifice with this heat sink it's a bit
longer than the PCB and to be more
precise the cord is 11 and 1/4 in in
length which realistically shouldn't
cause any installation problems into
most ATX and larger cases but keep a
note of this if you are looking for a
more compact chassis the high
performance fans are engineered to
maximize downwards air flow without
requiring fast rotational speeds uh and
they have a unique triangular Edge in
thin strips at their midpoints um and
this helps Grant a 23% airf flow
increase over traditional units gigabyte
has also replaced the windforce logo
with their own brand name uh there's a
fan stop sign which lights up to
indicate that the fan stop spinning in
low low situations uh the single 8pin
power input is also located here the
back plate is clean and simple nothing
too fancy when compared to competing
solutions from the likes of Zotac and
EVGA it gets a job done and all the
critical components located on this side
of the PCB should also benefit from its
additional heat dissipation
characteristics the I here is based off
the reference design you get three
display port 1.4 outputs a single HDMI
2.0 port and one DVID D connector
speaking about the software the Extreme
Engine app is a massive departure from
gigabytes OC Guru we've been seeing for
the last few Generations this one is
Sleek well-designed and highly intuitive
uh there's a section with full control
over a single backlit RGB logo a
dedicated fan profile area and a
userfriendly overclocking tab unlike
previous softwares there's no hidden
settings or Oddball toggle switches
everything is right there ready to be
used I actually appreciate its
functionality more than the new position
but it's missing EJ's straightforward
perpoint voltage modifiers uh and
instead uses a confusing curve likee
approach which didn't seem to have any
discernable impact on overclocking and
let's talk temperatures they're all
identical between different presets with
all topping out at 70° C essentially all
these modes strive to attain 70c simply
by fluctuating fan speeds or frequency
output in the long term the temperatures
were a bit lower than the superclocked
ACX 3.0 there were no differences
between fan speeds on both the gaming
and Eco modes with the only exception
that being Eco tends to hold the Fan's
idle a bit longer OC mode on the other
hand sees its rot speeds hitting about
150 RPMs higher than the other two even
though the new windforce 3x cooler has
three fans and a massive heat sink it
seems to be a bit inefficient when
compared directly against evj competing
solution once again the differences
between gaming and EC modes are
non-existent with frequencies hovering
between the 1885 MHz and 1873 MHz Mark
the OC mode does exhibit a bit more
fluctuation but it is indeed
consistently higher than the the other
two settings though only about by 50 MHz
and to me this makes gigabytes card a
dual mode solution rather than the
triple modes their extreme tuning
utility would lead you to believe all
right game time how well does this card
compare with the competition let's find
out
[Music]
well I think we found one of the fastest
GTX 1080s for now as you can see the G1
topsar charts in every single title at
the highest setting in 1440p overtaking
the superclocked ACX 3.0 but most
importantly destroying the founders
Edition the same story applies for 4K
with the G1 not letting anyone take its
place
[Music]
on the acoustic side there's really
nothing to get excited about especially
when OC mode is activated the EVGA
superclock 1080 is quieted across the
board but we can't forget it also
features slightly higher temperatures
power consumption is respectable too but
uh that's expected with the Pascal's
architecture again you have to consider
the three fans and the upgraded PCB into
the equation nonetheless there's no need
for a beefy power supply we were
disappointed with overclocking the
maximum achievable overclock was 2050
MHz placing the G1 gaming well behind
the founders Edition and the Super Clock
1080 the core on this particular sample
seems to require more voltage to run at
higher clocks than gigabytes utility can
provide even with an 8% power limit
increase our sample feels like a
plug-and-play solution which doesn't
need to be overclocked to hit Optimal
Performance the dark base 900 may be the
most Innovative case of the year with a
built-in chat charger interior lighting
tempered glass that can be installed on
either side and a fully modular interior
that can be inverted if you so desire be
quiet stepping up their game check it
out in description
below all right so what's our final
verdict on the GTX 1080 G1 from gigabyte
it's an awesome card loaded with great
features like RGB lighting upgraded PCI
components and some items that similarly
priced competing Solutions just don't
offer uh the addition of simple
Performance Tuning with just a click of
a button is an awesome feature
especially for beginners and performance
was outstanding across the board too
even when compared to the superclocked
1080 from EVGA unfortunately uh running
this card at default settings it was
just louder than the EVGA card and we
were not able to achieve the greatest
overclocking results either luckily
overclocking will likely vary from one
sample to the next with some being
better than the others while those
somewhat higher fan speeds can be tammed
with a few inputs into gigabyte software
and with all that taken into account if
you are looking for a featur rich GTX
108 then the G1 gaming can be considered
a good value for the performance it
provides so what do you guys think about
gigabytes G1 GTX 1080 gaming video card
uh would you pick this over EVGA
superclocked card card let us know in
the comments down below I'm EO with hin
X thank you so much for watching and
we'll see you in the next one